this video opens with Joe be like man we
just talk about real [ __ ] and then he's
like he's like put socks in the battery
and [ __ ] hit your [ __ ] with it
he's like the first guy to talk
[Music]
welcome back to another careful boys
where we are indeed very careful boys
today we are talking about how we can be
better for our significant others
Anthony
um repeat the question how can you be
better for your significant other people
that uh [ __ ] damn I'm on the spot
already
number one you should always cheat
number two
you should never work and let them do
all the work because you could collect
good payments like that and chill very
good number three
talk [ __ ] to them so they'll stay yeah
number four put a chip on the shoulder
huh put a chip on their shoulder write
it down kid write it down guys yeah
nagging uh okay like no it's just Joe's
been watching Fresh and fit too
I watched that this morning what you did
those guys are wild boys dude they'd be
saying some crazy [ __ ] I'm just curious
like because a lot of people are like oh
you guys should be watching or you
should bring them on or whatever right
and then um somebody hurt those guys
yeah I would love dating tips that are
useful in the Florida club scene right
exactly yeah that's exactly what I
thought I was just like oh these are the
kind of guys that just go to the the
parties like in Hollywood or whatever
and then those are the kind of girls
that like go to they every week and
their masters of that yeah like I
remember doing that I remember seeing
that in college and whatever so I get it
um but their mentality on dating in the
world is just that I agree yeah it's
like that yeah they won't get girls like
Games Workshop in Pasadena no no Prime
Time real estate baby you think they go
to the Renaissance Fair and get get laid
probably not no first of all all the
Honeys at the Renaissance Fair have
bosom you know what I'm talking about
that's what they call them too is that
premeditated Muslim for sure it is right
they got the pickles in there a little
yeah that's wild bro I was pre-meditated
throwing that out there we looking for
troll answers living serious though
serious stuff but obviously I'm having a
[ __ ] ball
and this is why we can't have serious
conversation today I'm very serious
person I know right I never know what
your eyes are I don't know who you're
looking at all right I was just I was no
seriously I was just telling Colleen
that we used to have actual discussions
but we have so much [ __ ] fun now that
no discussions really get there anymore
well we had quite a few discussions
while you were gone oh really
that's boring
experience that we are a lot of Heart to
Heart a lot of uh crying yeah yeah sorry
Anthony oh [ __ ]
um serious answers uh I could probably
um
build better and stronger Bridges and
relationships to her family let's get
closer to her family it's real yeah too
real too fast no that's good no that's
good I should have eased into it no
you're right because that yeah how do
you think you've you haven't done that
like like I don't think it's a matter of
having it but I think
um that like
maybe like her her family uh all of her
sisters have children and stuff so like
it's it's oftentimes like every every
time we hang out it's a lot of like the
kids or the pets or like just family in
general but like making a more direct or
personal effort to like build like a
one-on-one relationship with her sister
or like a brother-in-law or something
like that I feel like maybe could just I
don't know deepen bonds and stuff or
like just improve the chemistry overall
when we do see each other or even being
willing to like talk to them outside of
group text I don't know if anybody else
like has like you know especially with
your significant others if you already
have individual group text or I mean uh
individual texts with like siblings I
don't really have that I have like group
texts with like her siblings and stuff
like that you know what I mean for sure
but yeah I think I could build better
Bridges I DM Hannah's dad I slide into
his DMS yeah what do you saying we talk
about cars and how goofy Hannah is
that's really precious yeah and then um
her mom she hits me up on uh WhatsApp so
her dad hits me up on my on Instagram
because he like we like to flood on
Instagram and then but her mom is more
personal so we talk on WhatsApp that's
cute yep and then she's always talking
about how like much we're doing a good
job in life that's cute that's amazing
she watches the insta the all of our
videos on YouTube and all that and then
oh good she got to see you open this
video talk about like treated like [ __ ]
I think she stopped watching JK news
because
um
uh yeah I was just we're talking about
too much sexual [ __ ] together
a real [ __ ] and he's like he's like put
socks in the battery and [ __ ] hit
your [ __ ] with it
he's like the first guy to talk she's
probably like yeah you know I don't want
Hannah to go on a hot seat to see to
hear which parent she would [ __ ] she
said that I'm pretty sure that's what
she's gonna say next oh [ __ ] I thought
she worked for herself I'm like oh man
she really watches I would say we would
make an exception for her but I don't
trust myself no you gotta go hard and
she'd probably answer it too she would
answer I'm loyal to this show I wouldn't
do that to her it's just it's a it's the
seat that I respect exactly you know
what I mean exactly yeah I don't have a
relationship with her brothers yet but
then um her parents are [ __ ] dope as
hell and I do think you're right like
just building that Bond it's like
solidifying that unit together you're
not just [ __ ] buddies in a bed and just
you like to have [ __ ] late night
dinners together which are most
relationships now you're building ties
to family members and you're like yo
this is the long run yeah I recently got
to hang out with my in-laws and uh I
always say got to because I actually
really look forward to hanging out with
them they're always been chill I think
they're kind of they're younger because
Nikki was like an oopsie baby it's like
they were like 18 when they had her and
so Nikki's like folks like her dad like
a couple years years ago I'll never
forget him like being him just talking
about our family like me and Nikki's
brother and her mom and and he's like
this is our core and I I just about like
got all choked up that's sick I was like
damn I'm like [ __ ] him he was telling
you he's like this is our core well he
was saying it to respect it oh I hope
you thought of it I hope you thought it
was in I hope you thought it wasn't you
are and dude you're in the circle you
need the Fockers in the circle yeah I
mean no but I really thought that um
because Nikki always told me she's like
man I know he's brought guys home and I
brought so many guys home I brought so
many like different dudes home
like many many different men
um and my dad only liked you
and she's like trust me I brought a lot
of guys and I was like wow this is
really an honor you know I feel like you
keep saying that thousands and thousands
of guys and none of them can't tell you
how many guys I've said many men many
many but this guy but I think that it
was because I just give him respect like
when I met him like it's like shake the
hand look at the eye like all that kind
of [ __ ] you know I can't see your eyes
[ __ ] do that [ __ ] though you got a
[ __ ] girl
but but I but yeah I know I I am but as
far as what I could get better at for
Nikki I think that I do an amazing job
maybe you can just accept it what is it
so maybe you can just accept the pillows
oh not the pillows dude edit that out
can't do that isn't it comfortable
having a lot of pillows because I used
to judge that [ __ ] because I'm like I
only need like one or two and then after
you experience the pillow game and
you're like wow there's so many clouds
to sleep on I don't think so Joe I mean
they end up on the floor when you wake
up but that's the thing it's like and
then you gotta [ __ ] put them all in
the bed it's crazy that's Madness that's
the definition you have to do it Hey
listen I'm sorry I brought it up let's
just move on I have to do it because
she's like when you don't make the bed I
feel disrespected and I'm like God oh
yeah so then I gotta [ __ ] take 89
pillows and put them in an arrangement
damn well you could put them all in a
sheets wrap it up tie it in a big size
made the bed it's a dumpling since it's
November you should make like a big ass
Cornucopia just put pillows in it that
is really good actually that's easy
yeah um but no somebody I could actually
do better for Nikki I think it is
prioritizing date nights again because
we kind of we kind of moved into into
Vegas and we [ __ ] love it so much and
we spent a lot of time like hanging out
with neighbors and like friends and
stuff but like bringing it back in and
like we we do hang out at home a lot
especially post color things got into
that like kind of thing that everyone
gets into where it's like we're gonna
hang out at home and we're gonna watch a
cool show or something yeah but I think
making sure that we go somewhere and
experience something together
um prioritizing that like weekly or
whatever we can do schedule wise would
be agreed yeah I want to do that one
that coveted flow really gets you yeah
so comfy so nice it's too comfy yeah
yeah because I would I would probably
piggyback off that that's probably one
of the things real original Nick I know
but it's true though like you know feel
free to add on to the conversation I'm
going to I'm going to I'm going to
um but no everything else I do is
perfect right about now I could probably
shut up more I probably close my mouth
more that'd be good at the house
because you want me to add more
when she's opening up about [ __ ] maybe
you're trying to solve [ __ ] like we yeah
like like we've a lot I relate to Steve
a lot because when he talks about things
with his significant other I'm like yeah
I do the same [ __ ] bro because you
brought that up a long time ago around
the show and you were talking about how
like sometimes you're always like oh but
how about did you try this did you try
this and made me think about it this way
and she's like shut the [ __ ] up dude
shut your goddamn mouth and I'm like
yeah you're right
this would make my life way easier so
like shutting my mouth is probably
definitely top-notch and I think across
the board I think [ __ ] in my mouth is
very helpful
um but then also quality time like
actually crafting times where
so much of our day and when we hang out
is with family members other friends and
then like we just have all these events
we have to [ __ ] do and all this stuff
and then we get wrapped up and we don't
have any time for ourselves and that's
lame so me and Steve are gonna double
date dude we're gonna we're gonna figure
it out but yeah no like sitting down and
crafting time and
figuring out what's creative to do with
the signal others is tough I'm done a
couple days sometimes it was a double
date dude oh dude that's black dude no
yeah maybe one time I don't I feel sick
we should do a JK you know they they got
the whole medical field thing that maybe
they could talk about and then we we
like the book oh yeah you can talk about
work together they love that they love
their work I'm sure speaking of I think
a lot of us have kind of a blend of uh
family business experience like with our
significant other right like you have a
photo studio like
we kind of you you have a podcast you
know so it's like we have cats it's
family that bland though is like it's a
little bit
it does make it where like it blurs the
line between like are we talking about
work or am I here supporting you and
like we're venting yeah because then one
can get mixed with the other and then so
like but you know if your partner needs
to vent and you just got to be there for
support but then you're trying to like
troubleshoot because you think it's a
work thing I feel like that is what I
wish I knew but you know because like
girls are like really good at that like
they'll be like okay it's it's that vent
mode we just gotta get it out and then
we could think about how we're gonna
solve it and then move on right whereas
like the way we do it I guess most guys
it's more like oh tell me your problem
all right you should do this this and
this and then we're like oh that's a
good idea how about I do it like this
and then you go back and solve the
problem but then that works I think in a
work environment because it's solution
based but then my when she talks about
work and then I'm also involved in the
work it always goes to that so that
seeps into the the personal aspect of
your life yes yes it's hard to
distinguish what you're actually trying
to solve right because then it's like
maybe I just needed like you said shut
the [ __ ] up and like oh wait this is
event session so like let me just be
there for that or I get a job with her I
get a job with her and then then I can
give her constructive feedback oh that's
good I'll be a social worker with her if
I'm her boss
[Laughter]
if I'm a co-worker so I I asked her if
if you could preface it like is this
event or whatever but then I also in the
moment it's hard because then she needs
to get it out too and I get it so it's
my last moment like do you want a
solution or do you just want to listen
instead of asking it's just you just
preference it but isn't that that's also
really hard for this isn't it also kind
of condescending to say that it's like
you want a solution honey or do you want
me you want me to just
well I guess I mean the tone really
makes it it doesn't yeah it's like if I
could just sit here and blink if you
want you know it's a little bit I'm
lucky because I get to communicate that
way and then like it works but yeah like
not everyone does so I I think it's all
it's more about me being able to
recognize that I need to communicate
that because I just go immediately into
oh you should do this this and this
because I got the answer versus like oh
that sucks tell me about your day you
know you're never with Mike song He's
like I just need to talk right now I
just don't give me Solutions
I'm that guy I just need you to hear me
no Solutions I think the most of the the
Blurred stuff is when it's solvable
issues that I have experience in so for
example if it's like in
like let's say
um sales or management or something that
she's just unsure of and she's annoyed
about someone doing it a certain way and
then I can't tell the difference between
that and a work question and work
annoyance because it is involving work
and it's something that I know something
about so then so then when it's too
blurred like that then that's when it's
like I see myself being too preachy or
lectri or or bossy and then it's like oh
I should take a step back because that
wasn't what what it was it's good to see
that that's really good but then other
aspects like you know I I think I I can
clearly see the lines now whereas in the
past I think like I didn't know even
what venting was like when a girl just
starts venting I would just start
telling her oh that's stupid you got to
do it this way like all dumb young boys
right they all do the same [ __ ] yeah and
then later you go oh wait wait they they
solve it differently going back to the
Quality timeout aspect of it if you're
already with that person all the time
then it's difficult to want to spend
more time because you want now you want
alone time yes I think you need new
experiences especially for a variety of
different people yeah you need to just
find things that maybe you both are
interested in doing and yeah have an
activity I think for me like most
I think it's like some of the common
stuff like stop trying to have an alert
go off when you go oh this is a
teachable moment I should tell her this
is how this goes I think I need to shut
the [ __ ] up when those things happen
because they're not like we're both
[ __ ] learning yeah um and I think in
general just this is a [ __ ] heavy one
to say but like
I think I think I'm a I'm a really good
boyfriend and I don't but I don't think
I'm developing all of the best ways to
be a good husband
and I think those are a different like
set of features can you yeah dive into
that a little bit just like uh it could
range from something so simple as like
just knowing how to cook a lot of things
you know like uh ways that I would be a
good dad you know like things that maybe
I haven't even thought about but like
for so many years like we've been
together like six years and I've
cultivated a lot of things that are
really fun or really like uh you know we
we have a great time together but in
terms of like responsibility aspects or
just like long-term big picture things
like I I know I haven't thought about it
as much so lately I've been trying to do
more things like that are you trying to
this could be very personal what colors
if you want to even kind of [ __ ] all day
like that's why we dance I know let's
talk about relationships they love that
cutting everything well we got to be
respectful right we gotta be open
personal lives or personal lives we're
not talking about ourselves anymore
you're talking about somebody else
exactly gotta be protective of our
people
um but you know are you trying to is it
like something where you're like I don't
think she's ready to be my wife yet or
is it like you're trying to be even
better for that step we're pretty open
about talking about what we want to do
and I um it's more on my end like I
think I don't think there's anything she
has to change really it's just I think
I'm such a I'm such a boy about a lot of
things
and I'm aware I'm like self-aware of
that [ __ ] like uh dude like I'm the way
that I I kind of my mentality is by
default is very much more like a like a
guy and not like as man as it could be
in my ideal so you're trying to make
sure you're you're trying to mature your
zany side or your wild side yeah I mean
I mean I I want to retain those things
but like I think in general life skills
wise
um there's I'm better at a lot of things
that a man doesn't necessarily need
and I think very core skills like this
is a good conversation starter I
actually want to expand on them but it's
already the 20 minute Mark should we do
it yeah
no but we already cut out 18 minutes of
stuff yeah that's true yeah I think
that's and that's something that every
person like every guy will have their
own Journey on that yeah but there is
going to come a time where you will sort
of see that shift and I think I'm just
kind of late to the game a little bit
you know like uh and like everything
around the house like I tried to over
the past couple of years I've tried to
like find more practical uh skills like
how to fix things myself how to like do
things like stuff that I remember my dad
doing probably at a way younger age than
I did you know just like real skills you
know
um if you're not yelling while you're
trying to fix something you're not a man
yeah if your ass crack isn't sticking
out up top you know what I mean
you know just like different things and
you know I I try to provide in I think
modern ways like I I'll order food all
the time for her which is nice I'm hella
skilled at that yeah I know but like I
wanna also cook and I know she she would
love that but rather than invest the
time to get better at that there's it's
so easy to just go oh well like she
loves this I'll just order that but it's
like I know that like in the long term
like you have to learn how to do that
very well and you know it's not
something that just happens do you think
our kids will be watching all that
happened and then they're like on a JK
later and they're like like man my dad
used to order food like this I'm like I
don't know how to do it that confidently
like I'm like
and now my kid's gonna go that's why the
food sucks around here yeah because Dad
can't cook or just in the future they
just push the little buttons and just
like little paste comes out and that's
like the flavor of a cheeseburger
what I want to ask the question of is
what is that definition of being that
epitome of a man yeah because then
because then for him like it sounds like
your ideal is here and you're here and
you're not there ready yet like you
don't deserve being a husband and and
you're not up to par to your ideal I
think it's it's all along where you're
shifting your focus it's like I don't
expect to become the [ __ ] you know
Tim Allen of you know what my world is
but I think like it's where I'm
investing my awareness it's like oh like
I I know that I'm doing this for this
reason I like what what other
motivations are to learn first aid other
than to know that like oh if [ __ ] goes
down as the well you gotta learn first
aid in order to get certain ranks in boy
scouting so yeah but those are man
skills right because I know a lot of
people with man skills but they're boys
yeah so I think that's a good talk to
talk about and part too it's a good talk
to talk about don't forget that folks
let's keep talking we did do we did do
what's the definition of man when Joe
was gone but we this is kind of a an
extension of that yeah was it that in
the context of like a trans person there
was no no but this one this one's more
sitting down and making sure that you
know it's an intervention with Joe got
it I got it this one's a gender role
this one's a harmful gender role
foreign